my primary goal is a scientist has been
to just learn as much as we can first
about the elements of the system and now
that we know some of the elements how it
works I mean of course there's interest
in using this information to develop new
therapeutics and that can happen any
number of ways
one would be to inject leptin and see if
it has biological effects what's been
evident over the last decade or so is
that in some circumstances leptin has
very powerful biological effects but in
others less so
and so leptin is a single therapy for
obesity is proven to be a variable
benefit more recently there's however
been some evidence that if you pair
leptin with other agents you can
substantially reduce weight and so there
are clinical studies ongoing to test
whether leptin might be part of a
therapeutic regimen to treat obesity I
think in the longer term however the
more we learn about how this system
works the more a better the better able
we're going to be to intervene in the
form of drugs that modulate the behavior
of neural pathways that regulate weight
and so I think the future you know does
put forth the promise of new treatments
for obesity but I think there's an
important caveat here which is to ask
what is it are we treating I think
there's a disconnect in fact between the
way I think about this problem and the
way the public might think about it